[Music]
what is this sound
do you hear that
it's like some warbled screaming
happening uh hello everybody my name is
markiplier welcome back to inscription i
almost said subscription but that's what
you guys should do along with liking
commenting and favoriting
cut all this out anyway so we got that
done
that was easy enough i'm gonna save the
tech land for last just because it seems
to be like that's what i would do to
fight this dude
and uh you know i don't think i'm ready
for that i'm gonna go to the store
though and see if i can buy anything not
that i really want to i don't really
have anything to buy
and i don't know what to do with all the
pelts i would have thought that there
would have been something in the um
the forested area for the pelts but i
haven't seen anything there was that it
was this it looks like there's something
there but clearly not
let me just yeah i'll be right back let
me just scan
whoa what is that
what
oh what the [ __ ] is this what is this in
june 6 2006 found this old picture of
when elle and i first got into aquaro
man's gilly gladiator sick l got a
julius caester
okay
ah
interesting so there is stuff back here
if you revisit
there's stuff to find
and i bet there's probably secret pass
that could open up you're not supposed
to be there
where did you come from
i'll fight you fine whatever
i'm fine with that
i'm down to throw down
always anytime and forever because also
you give me energy now i forgot about
that i love you
i love you i don't need energy bots
anymore
i love you
empty vessel
also i have an energy bot so i guess
it's not an entire waste but
oh my god i almost have five already oh
i love this
i love all of this
oh i love this i would double gun but i
don't seem to have the space for it
wow my energy bots of course they all
come up now this is when they would i'm
gonna blow everything up
have fun
oh
all right good
good good good this is exactly what i'd
hoped for
oh
why do i have so many energy bots i
didn't think i had this many energy
butts
ever
i forgot that i got that here comes the
overkill oh
my god
yes please and thank you i will take
that money thank you very much thank you
thank you i forgot that that existed i
need to get some of these things out of
my hand like the energy bots
i need to just purge them
okay let me go back up in here and see
if there's like a path that opened up or
something hello again just me don't mind
me okay so there was nothing there i
wonder if i go back to the cemetery if
there might be something back this way
because i doubt that i was being very
dedicated on checking these other
paths
from the get-go
no no no
oh there is something here
chump change to what my riverous can get
me but fine
very interesting okay so it was just one
file huh i don't know what all that's
tying into but thankfully the lucky
carter here is always on our side to
make sure that we stay on the path
can i get rid of some cards ugh i don't
want more cards wasn't there a way
i thought there used to be a way to like
get rid of cards or not accept these
cards i i didn't remember always having
to take them but apparently i do hi bud
got you thank you don't know what all
these sentries are about that rabbit was
doomed no matter what
[Music]
thank you for the money hello how are
you
it's fixed you can go on your merry way
oh i didn't even know you were doing
that
what you're not so merry being a pawn in
this petrol and androids plot isn't
doing it for you
reloading personality matrix it's fixed
all right it's fixed i guess
i didn't know it was broken
hi
i love this
hello alarmbot you're looking spiffy
oh
hey who are you tank macabre's here
let's get down to business okay fine
no pleasantries just straight to
business
a little rude
and you get fragile all right goodbye
now
maybe i need a last one more
i think it's got one more life left in
them
and then it's gone
oh no no no ah no no
you
[ __ ]
you [ __ ]
god damn it i forgot about how that was
gonna work god
damn it
dagnabbit dammit dagnabbit nab the
dagget
all right it's fine everything's fine
i wouldn't worry about a thing
i wouldn't worry about a nothing
wouldn't worry about a thing
oh
hey
i just want my ribber rubbers
i just want to get my ribroos
oh i need to draw the real cards not
those cards if i want my
ribarus
[Music]
there's no way i'm ever gonna get it
so
[Music]
okay i win no no no no no i can see
let's move on no no no i was i'm not
done i'm not i'm not done i was go oh
i guess he won't wait until i can just
get a bajillion things so whatever what
if i don't concede
what if i don't feel like conceding
[Music]
all right well a little bit is better
than none i guess
not that i'm gonna do anything with the
money anyway don't need it all right
oh was that a recycle
you will destroy one of your cards now
don't be an idiot this is better than
getting a new one i know makes your deck
more consistent and it'll give you robux
for it oh yes please take my energy bot
take it
thank you can i get more can i throw
more away
can i do more i would love to do more
thank you thank you
thank you can i throw more nope okay
what's up here
uh
[Music]
uh oh there's a file
i didn't think the archivist would dig
up this file another pic of l and i this
was for school but i remember it was
right after we won that tournament
together at comics land we told mom and
dad it was a spelling bee
is that the lucky carter
is that who that is
choose one
let's see oh you mean i can't let that
the dude get any more what are you
offering
what do we have
that's pretty good because then he can
always give gifts
i like that
i like that three abilities decent yes
very decent i like that a lot i like
that very much so
i like that excessively
i don't like getting new car i don't
have to click on them why did i do that
busted 3d printer once a card bearing
the schedule struck draw a card from
your empty vessel pile
i
i like that i like that i like that a
lot i like that that's pretty good whack
it with a hammer get me more vessels
give me more energy a lot quicker
i like that
i like that a lot
i like that very much so
[Music]
all right
okay
[Music]
god damn it the energy bot still pops up
no matter what i do it's fine
totally fine
[Music]
back in my favor
fishbot what happens if i play you
i'm gonna do a thing
play you
kill you
give me that card bad fish and fishbot
comes back then i can
basically just play you again not that
you do anything against that one
but eventually you'd kill it right
the fish gun
gets me every time
oh yeah you turn into a
snake a fish snake
[Music]
i love it so i love it so
i love it so
i could probably do with powering it up
even more but i think 25 is more than
enough i don't think i'm ever going to
need more than 25.
kind of instantly lethal on any anything
basically i get a river rivers and i win
items 100 charge boss spawners 100
offline all right so this would be
ah so i want to go south first
ah
yep oh no yep i forgot a piece you have
legs stand up and get it it's in the
smelter room floating above the smelting
machine i can't let you go further until
i have it
really getting kind of bright and
inviting in this room almost it's
awfully cheerful
uh
why is that floating
oh
hello
what was
that what was it
hi
hello
greetings the pain bearable the pressure
of these pipes surrounding me feels nice
that and the knowledge that the master
is near
okay oh yes the master is near i feel
his presence
that robot will rule the day
the pain bearable okay
yes hello can i help you
yes
still there's a little
okay all right
thanks buddy oh
there was clue here
that's what these were
there's a there's like a
skull on that one
there must be little okay so the bottom
one is the skull one definitely unless
it's not
skull
go back go the other way okay you can
only go one way
so i just gotta find the other ones
they're probably around here somewhere
okay enter the correct sum
two plus seven plus three
okay two okay so that's four plus four
minus four
that's
two plus three plus
six
five plus six eleven
okay
this is some good quizzes select all
applicable emotions for the following
scenarios you draw your energy bot you
have full energy yeah this um
yeah this is uh
yeah i feel that
i feel that
you are about to die from an insecta
drone you draw a leap bot
yay
oh
you successfully performed the great
transcendence
i mean sounds pretty great to me
sounds real great
if you ask me
what's with this
i don't know
hello oh
thank you
waiting for network ah
which sigil is represented uh that's
this
oh god um
i feel like it's this one
nah damn it
can't be that one it's gotta be this one
yeah
alarm clock ah damn it oh i can turn
them
oh
that's much more helpful
than just guessing ah
i see
i don't have to guess
ah
waiting for network okay
so there's some way to connect the
network maybe or maybe i just gotta wait
actually wait
okay so the thing is i definitely know
that one of them is skull
that's clear
looks like it might be the middle one
just the way it's like centered between
two other dots on the top and the bottom
let me try everything with it based in
the middle
damn it there's a lot of different ones
but this might reduce the complexity
down okay let's start with
that
let's uh circle back to the x every time
so we went to x on all that next one
7 8 9 10 11 12. there's 12. okay not
that
several brute force attempts later
okay this is weird i feel like i've
tried every combination that has the
skull and it didn't do anything is this
not actually a clue if this feels like a
clue i've done every combination of
skull that i possibly could now i could
go through everything very meticulously
and do it all one at a time but that
would take four times as long as i just
did it and i've wasted some time doing
that so i don't feel like doing it i'll
do it a little bit later hi
i brought the thing i don't know what it
is
yep good let's attach it
oh god i gotta deal with the runes these
things light up when you have gem vessel
cards in play your empty vessels are now
filled with gems check it out
good
oh you can change for the color of the
gems you draw from your side deck
okay
try it press one
oh
okay good
that's good
that's very good
you'll pick a card now and i'll gemify
it from then on having a green gem will
increase its health having an orange gem
will increase its power and having a
blue gem will lower its energy cost
you'll see okay
all right lonely wizbot you're getting
me even more powerful buddy
okay
oh
[Music]
uh
okay
see those things in the corners
they light up when you have the right
gems you'll see okay
okey-dokey then all right pal
hmm more secret paths huh
file
weird
done sorting and scanning all these
photos this last one last photos was
together before we lost her goodbye ss
that's the lucky carter
that's him
what's that all about
you know what to do i think i do all
right pop her in there fishbot
what do we have
let's see nah not good
battery i already have too much battery
bomb well this is lame
i guess hiding in front of people you
you really can't take a beating so it
kind of works out in your way and you
can't die and then you give me cards you
really filled up that one card all your
eggs in one basket smart thank you
thank you very much
really appreciate that so uh luke you
don't have anything to say about this
these files being in your game and all
that
nothing at all
[Music]
well you know what i'm gonna choose
i am choosing you
[Music]
okay it's gemified but why i don't
actually like the gemification process
something tells me i'm not gonna like
the gems
also i'm probably gonna completely
ignore them
ooh
i have one on the field interesting
i'm guessing i can't change it once it's
here
what is that a gem bound ripper
that sounds pretty extreme but okay see
i get an emerald and i'm gonna have a
sapphire so it's cost will be lower
so i'll put that there
and then this thing's cost is lower and
now i can play it
right
i should put that there but whatever i
would have lost it yeah this is good
bam
i'm feeling
stimulated good keep that to yourself
okay you keep that i forgot you got
snipey powers now bang
hell yeah
try to rip me try just try
all right
you tried
ruby huh
[Music]
freaking energy but
i hate you
i win
thank you very much that was a lovely
game never come back
be embarrassed forever
oh boy gentification all right fine i'll
go with sniper bot maybe i can give him
some more defense so he doesn't die
mm-hmm okay
now what
no i don't want more cards i've got so
many cards oh but they're pre-gemified
oh i don't want a gem detonator i don't
want to deal with any of that
that sounds like nonsense uh gem-bound
ripper
that's kind of fun
ooh a bomb challenge
okay okay
okay okay okay okay
oh you there
put you
i thought it was isn't that a blue one
oh
it's not ruby no i have one of each it
should be cheaper oh i guess he's
normally three that's right time is of
the essence so how many turns i got
no
that's not good
all right well i can't play that for a
bit
put you
there
i am fish you are a fish
i should have laid down a bomb right
away that would have taken care of most
of this i would have destroyed my side
more
oh well that's not good
oh that's marginally better it's still
not great
thanks not very helpful why am i even
worrying about the gems i don't care
i literally don't care why am i giving
it even a single moment of thought
just kill things and get through
that's the only thing that matters right
now i just gotta get through them
so that's what i'm gonna do i'm just
gonna get through them
i've got a path and i've got three turns
to do something about that path better
hurry yeah don't you worry about a thing
buddy don't you worry i'm all over it
swap bot damn you
a-hole
i'm gonna make a bit of an extreme move
it's not even that extreme
pretty normal actually when you really
think about it wham
damn it that was hoping it was going to
be a good fish
alas
it is not one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten now
brick i got this it's fine it'll make
it'll it'll work it'll work it'll work
it'll work i have two turns i have two
turns easy it's like it's nothing it's
like it's nothing
like nothing another double gunner you
know i love it
you know i love it you know
you know i love it
oh i did it
you did it you stopped it from exploding
i did it i didn't even need to worry
about it you are a hero is that enough
congratulations you can congratulate me
more if you want you know
i wouldn't say no you know
i'm not gonna say no
oh traveler these parts do not seem many
you wish to pass these blades
fine
thank you
okay cool
or lose vessel ah
all right i'll take the ripper
now give me something oh i don't know
what i'm gonna energy bot take it please
dear god get rid of it thank you
no i don't want more cards i literally
will not take that because i don't want
more cards now what was over here
i think this is the path back of course
but
just double checking also wasn't there
like an enemy over here or was there
nothing it was just that secret
okay
another fight
damn you
[Music]
damn both of you why are you both like
this
but i can shield bots
[Music]
easy
oh yeah okay well i got that checkpoint
that's helpful
oh what is that
what
what did i just do
[Music]
did do something in the building or did
it do something somewhere far away which
i think it might have done the guy used
to live here was a major drag well you
knew him you wanted to replace him guy
had a plan for every eventuality that is
except for the great transcendence
okay
sure man recycle yes please
um
[Music]
do i have to choose me did you say
choose me no thank you i'm gonna get rid
of my other energy bot uh goodbye
man no confirmation it just goes
oh no wait there's a confirmation go
i don't need it anyway grind it up into
dust practically paid for its own
recycling fee
that's how you know it's quality
or crap anyway what is that lipstick
it's a paintbrush
what is that
the hell is it
oh
didn't know it would do that but oh i
already did ah
i solved that puzzle already
no refunds i already solved the clock
suck my clock you [ __ ] that one's
still a mystery but um maybe there's
something oh whoa waiting network wait
network
network ah
i thought that was gonna be it i thought
that was gonna be it i thought i was so
smart
all right let's beef up something
hum diddly hum hum
uh busted 3d printer what could i give
you
i haven't even seen you yet but whatever
nah it's dumb
gift bot could give two presents that's
pretty cool
how about two presents from giftbot
oh we can't get present twice that's
dumb all right fine um
aurora bot could get presents every time
it dies
that'd be cool
yeah
really all right yeah thank you it's a
great move thank you very much
[Music]
uh
okay you're gonna blow up those gems and
that's gonna blow up my gem but i don't
really care because it doesn't really
matter
so much to see i know buddy i know i
know it's gonna be okay
you're gonna be just fine you're gonna
be a-okay all right okay um
yeah those are now bombs that guy's
dangerous but all right
[Music]
yep
and just shoot
oh
i could kill that one i guess
bam
nice try dude
i fish bought
i mean i basically won so i don't even
know why i'm thinking about it too hard
[Music]
easy
bam
nothing to do
but a win my deck is pretty good right
now so i like really have no qualms
about any of this it's it's pretty
straightforward if i get my ouroboros at
any time i win period except for maybe a
boss fight i don't know
all right can you gemify the aruba
remaro not that a little bit more damage
is gonna do anything but you know i'll
take it actually you know what i'm gonna
bother with that i have other things
that i could boost maybe gif bot i like
it i'll crystallize the gift bot i'll
make it nice put some
gems on there or something rhinestones
make it real pretty like
okay thank you that's very helpful
you're so sweet to me i don't know why
you want me to win this [ __ ] also let me
go out real quick there oh
all right i'll go out afterwards i'll go
afterwards there might be like a radio
tower in the top of this or something
like that i don't know
what do you got for me oh easy peasy you
think that's not easy breezy
hurry up i don't have all day
yeah
the
of excellence
[Music]
what is that what did he just play there
what is that gem guardian card bearing
this jewel has played all gem vessels on
the owner's side of the board gain nano
armor
oh well who cares do i care no i don't
care i don't really care
the thing is i actually do not care
i think that's dumb and i think you're
dumb for doing it
no good job you made it wow the oh
really good stuff man
real good yeah very good
okay i'm proud of you
proud of you
you really did it pal
i couldn't attack it it had armor
so smart good at this game all right
hi
okay so maybe it wasn't in this area
there might be something in the tech
area where i am because it's trying to
connect here so i would have to do that
first oh right this uber bot well you'll
see
i see a lot of mirrors or paintings hope
we get some mirrors there isn't one
there's no boss for this level that's
your job
oh
please
paint me a face
oh
yep
lunky is that you hi lunky god i'm born
i feel as though i can breathe now
oh
well you're gonna stop breathing pretty
soon another thing i'll need a special
power a game rule to call my own you
painted me such a beautiful face so
every time you play a card a random card
takes five damage i play a leap bot one
of my cards games enamel all cards take
one damage random card is played you
lose one life
okay every time a card dies every time
your turn starts
um
[Music]
take the one life that seems fun i like
the color combination
yeah definitely not every time i play a
card i lose one life
every time my turn starts let's do with
that one
that sounds fair
good this could work
let's see how this plays out
i'm gonna kill you and i'm sorry i
apologize for that but i am uh
not responsible for what is about to
happen and i apologize
profusely
okay uh
be nice i can't play anything just yet i
suppose i could get out the gate
that's fine i'll be fine
totally fine
[Music]
how'd you get to health
god i just lost a lot of
well that don't seem right
something don't seem right at all
hmm
you're gonna go there and this
exoskeleton is gonna kick your ass
it's gonna kick your ass buddy that's
gonna do two damage that's gonna pull me
back from the brink a bit i don't think
i'm gonna take any more damage after
that
that's fine thank you
all right we're doing good
doing good
doing just fine
just fine
shield bot good
i know it's not going to do anything but
just feels good to have that there
also the amy bot is uh snipey
wham
helpful
all right this is gonna be a two-phase
thing uh but uh it's about to end thanks
buddy
really appreciate you being a part of
this experience but uh
everything's gonna end sometime phil
fell
yep
uh
i guess he was about to kill it anyway
so what did it matter
miami bot
[Music]
almost ow
why would you do that to me
where's all my cards
uh this should finish the fight
[Music]
wham
i know it's not over over phase two
you picked such a cool mechanic for
phase one i think we should elaborate on
that design process
okay
[Music]
okay every time a car dies
one of my cards gains nano armor it's
like a protective thing constant pretty
cool right
oh
uh my sniper bot really does you
shouldn't oh no snipey boy oh god
stimulation i know i know pal i know um
look i'ma pop you on the board and i'm
gonna get some shieldage going on here
because there's a
quite a bit of a problem quite a bit of
a problem here uh
maybe i should just get rid of that
thing because that is gonna set off a
chain reaction or maybe i should get rid
of it now while everything has shields
that'll probably be helpful yeah let's
just do that
okay
good
wham
wham okay and there she goes wow
all good it's all good
so all good we're fine we're fine
everything's fine
ow
it's fine don't worry about it
all good
hell yeah
that's what i like to see
i love to see that i love to see it
and you know what else
you know what else
[Music]
yeah it's a bomb latcher it's not that
big a deal
whatever but this is more powerful now
so how about a little bit of this and a
little bit of that boom
man those are those are real bolts that
came out of there those weren't
holograms
i really blasted the bolts out of you
oh uh
i can't quite oh
i win
all right cool good cool good very good
[Music]
okay thank you
thank you
you're not very talkative right now you
don't have anything to say about that
you're
really quiet man you i feel like you
should be talking
or shields oh shields are sentry
ooh
i don't really care about them living i
care about them because i can always get
more i think sentry gun is cool
okay you you all right man you're very
quiet you don't have anything to say
about me uh destroying the shadow
version of my own self
you don't have anything to say about
that
interesting uh that you are so quiet
there's got to be something about that
network thing
but i
wonder if it's
not even here you know what i mean
hmm
if only i got that clue before i paid
for it yeah there's got to be something
here like another network relay or
something of the like or it's probably
just in the tech area which is up north
here
ah what is it you unlock the gate so
carry on
i have so many files to inspect oh
i did i did it
my face when i got to 100 subscribers on
my channel i started making those videos
to distract from grief i still can't
believe people like to watch them big
plans for the lucky carter this year
i know that feeling man
i remember that feeling good luck man i
know you're a fake youtuber but unless
you are real i don't know
especially with my brain alright so this
is the next phase i'm gonna go into
thank you everybody so much for watching
that's all the time i have for now thank
you to my 100 subscribers out there
really appreciate it
we all start our youtube channels under
different circumstances and we have
different journeys getting to where we
are
so wherever you are on yours
thank you for watching
and good luck
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]